telepathic dogs eerily topical pandemics
Mass infertility when it comes to
zombies disease or mass extinction these
films are the cream of the crop
apocalyptic films are teeming with The
Walking Dead nuclear threats and
catastrophic plagues but only one film
on this list sees the world Sizzle to a
crisp thanks to dragons set in the
totally not apocalyptic year of 2020
where dragons have replaced mankind as
the dominant species the paltry remnants
of the human race must work together to
ensure their survival maligned upon its
release and criminally underseen Reign
of Fire is much more interesting
visually stunning and sophisticated than
its goofy premise suggests with an
All-Star cast and some genuinely
jaw-dropping creature effects it's a
must watch for anyone who wants to see
the world burn this loose adaptation of
Richard Matheson's classic novel follows
scientist Robert Neville who is as far
as he can tell one of the last human
beings on Earth thanks to an attempt to
cure cancer that mutated into a deadly
virus most humans have become pallid
vampiric creatures balancing
mind-numbing loneliness with his
attempts to survive and develop a cure
Neville soon finds that he is far less
alone than he initially suspected
grounded by a heartfelt performance by
Will Smith and featuring more action
than the vast majority of films on this
list I Am Legend is a Punchy big budget
take on an apocalyptic or text
please say hello to me
this film tells of a uniquely terrifying
plague which only attacks strains of
grasses and greens including wheat and
rice in the wake of this catastrophe the
world descends into famine and
consequently chaos we follow an upper
middle class architect named John who
becomes the de facto patriarch of a
group of family friends and stragglers
as they make their way to the safe haven
of his brother's farm pay no attention
to the film's middling Rotten Tomato
score what no blade of grass lacks in
Polish and definer touch it more than
makes up for in Grim stifling ecological
Terror enduringly relevant and dystopian
no blade of grass is an essential watch
for anyone with a taste for the dreary
hopeless Outlook of 1970s science
fiction Ralph Burton is a miner who is
trapped underground while nuclear
Holocaust wipes out all of humanity
emerging to find New York City deserted
Ralph assumes he's the last man on Earth
and starts acting like it eventually
Ralph meets Sarah a fellow Survivor
however however their Dynamic is soon
disturbed by the arrival of another
Survivor starring the trailblazing
screen star and activist Harry Belafonte
the World the Flesh and the devil feels
like a lost Twilight Zone episode
filtered through the lens of Richard
Matheson tackling its societal themes
head on and highlighting Belafonte's
undeniable screen presence this film is
an unmissable and decidedly more
optimistic entry in apocalyptic Cinema
Sunshine dramatizes a horrific
world-ending scenario the sun is dying
as the planet is thrust into colder and
colder temperatures a team of crack
astronauts are sent to Kickstart the
all-important Star by firing a nuclear
bomb into its core full of incredible
visuals and shocking horror beats
particularly in the third act Sunshine
is an enthralling and Atmospheric slice
of Science Fiction with Stakes that
don't just threaten Humanity but our
whole solar system this sci-fi's
survival horror film and Cloverfield
sequel follows Michelle a young woman
woman who wakes up in an underground
bunker after a violent roadside accident
unsettled by her domineering captor
Howard who claims the air outside is
toxic and she cannot leave under any
circumstances resourceful Michelle sets
about plotting her Escape please just
let me go please there's nowhere to go
Michelle this economically paced and
wildly tense single location Thriller
boasts numerous top shelf performances
and a claustrophobic sense of unease if
the world ended and you were trapped
underground with an overbearing psycho
what would you do from its title you'd
be forgiven for mistaking this film for
some kind of adorable Seaside romantic
comedy it is in fact about an atomic war
that wipes out all organic life in the
northern hemisphere a surviving Yankee
submarine finds respite in Australia
which appears to be one of the few safe
harbors on Earth where many films on
this list Veer into action or hard
sci-fi territory on the beach opts for
melodrama sure there's still plenty of
nihilism in social commentary but on the
whole it feels much more like an
existential soap opera than an explosion
heavy Thriller on the beach pulls this
off by featuring a powerful ensemble
cast full of big name Talent adapted
from the 1962 French film legite 12
Monkeys follows James Cole a convict
from the year 2035 sent through time to
find a solution to the world's dark fate
in 1996 a deadly virus of Unknown Origin
eradicated almost all life on Earth
forcing those who survived underground
the plan is to send Cole back to the day
of the outbreak to learn how it all went
down but when he's accidentally
transported too far back his warnings of
the end of days land him in a mental
hospital boasting evocative production
design and expectations of birding
performances from its two male leads 12
Monkeys is a frantic doom-filled ride
with both style and substance a boy and
his dog takes place in the barren
radiated wastes of 2024. our hero is Vic
a morally suspect teenage boy who
wanders from one bombed out hole in the
ground to the next in search of food and
women along for the ride is blood a
telepathic Dog full of Rye commentary
charity is a thing of the past this film
is Bleak perverse and offbeat AKA The
Holy Trinity of 1970s apocalyptic
science fiction if you shook your fists
at those who held super spreader House
parties during the covid-19 pandemic boy
have we got a film for you a top shelf
product of Roger Corman and Vincent
Price's Yen for Edgar Allan Poe
adaptations the mask of the Red Death
follows Prince Prospero a hedonistic
Satanist who is resolved to lock himself
and his party guests in his enormous
Castle to Stave off the terrible plague
known as the Red Death full of Cruelty
scene chewing and gorgeous production
design realized in jaw-dropping
Technicolor the mask of the Red Death is
a lavish visual Feast of Gothic Delights
that overcomes its budgetary limitations
to deliver one of the most striking
products of corman's career one animal
rights activists unwittingly release a
rabies-like virus onto the British
public the country is catapulted back to
the dark ages four weeks later a man
named Jim wakes up from a coma and
surveys the wreckage of what used to be
London rescued by a group of survivors
Jim finds that infected humans now stalk
the streets transformed into frothing
homicidal Maniacs infusing the zombie
genre with Kinetic New Life 28 Days
Later proved the zombie genre still had
life in it yet in the aftermath of a
top-secret experiment designed to create
a global energy source a scientist named
Zach Hobson awakens to find that he is
the last person alive on Earth or so he
thinks soon Hopsin happens upon two
other survivors as the trio discovers
the common cause behind their survival
their emerging love triangle takes a
back seat to Hobson's Revelation that
the full extent of the experiment's
pernicious effects have yet to reveal
themselves overwhelmingly cryptic and
appropriately lonely the quiet Earth is
a gorgeously photographed low budget gem
grounded by three soul-wrenching lead
performances
boasting an incredible ensemble cast and
an unsettling degree of plausibility
contagion details the arrival and
Fallout of an Airborne viral pandemic
this film's procedural plot makes the
spread that much more compelling and
terrifying we follow the illness as it
takes root spots conspiracy theories and
destabilizes Society contagion makes
particularly major use of soderberg's
talent for depicting catastrophes and
hypercompetence in equal measure this
film was a nerve-wracking watch in 2011
and has only become more uncanny and
unsettling in the wake of the eerily
similar covid-19 pandemic this iconic
film may not initially read as
apocalyptic fission but brace herself
for a 60 year old spoiler when the
plot's larger context is ultimately
revealed its qualification as end of day
Cinema becomes painfully ironically
obvious this film follows George Taylor
an astronaut stranded on a strange
Planet dominated by sentient ape-like
creatures who use human captives for
sport and scientific experiments
cause of me you damn dirty ape still one
of the bleakest films to come out of
Hollywood Planet of the Apes features a
grounded performance by Roddy McDowell
as the benevolent chimp Dr Cornelius and
closes with one of the most infamous
Final Shots in all of Cinema
when Curtis begins to experience
terrifying hallucinations he seeks
medical help and counseling while
Curtis's work and family suffer in the
wake of his violent outbursts and
horrifying visions of environmental
catastrophe he can't shake the feeling
that something truly terrible is on the
horizon are these dreams a genuine
premonition of an incoming apocalypse or
are they actually the onset of the
inherited schizophrenia he's feared his
whole life a genuinely gripping portrait
of the erosive effects of undiagnosed
mental illness take shelter is a
gripping anxiety-riddled viewing
experience grounded by a gut-wrenching
lead performance from Michael Shannon
just as Harry is preparing to go on his
first date with his dream girl he
accidentally receives a chilling tip-off
that nuclear missiles are going to
destroy Los Angeles in less than an hour
while Harry initially laughs off the
information is a cruel joke or the
ravings of a Madman he soon learns that
the threat is very real and very
imminent balancing endearingly
unrelenting romantic idealism with an
undeniable sense of hopelessness this
Tangerine Dream scored neon lit Terror
trip is a love story for the end times
this genre-defying future debut follows
biangu an unemployed conspiracy nut who
has convinced himself that his former
employer is an evil alien who intends to
take over the planet as such biangu of
ducks his boss and tortures him in a
Subterranean dungeon as his paranoia
spreads and his alien torture operation
grows larger and larger the resultant
chaos grows ever more intense genre
defying and delightfully ridiculous
there is no film quite like save the
Green Planet and for that fakalo it's
well worth seeking out directed by the
Australian auteur Peter Weir the last
wave follows David Burton a taxation
lawyer who is hired to act as the
defense in a murder case involving the
death of an Aboriginal man during a
freak rainstorm when Burton begins to
experience bizarre watery dreams he
starts to agree with the accused the
strange weather patterns are a sign of
an incoming apocalypse ambiguous and
lyrical the last wave is steeped in
otherworldly strangeness as reality
refuses to sit still history may
remember Saul bass for his graphic
design but fans of apocalyptic fiction
know his first and only directorial
effort stands toe-to-toe with the
kinetic typography of psycho a pair of
scientific researchers in the Arizona
desert find themselves held captive by
the objects of their study a colony
events who have begun acting strangely
in the wake of an unprecedented Cosmic
event as the global implications of
their ant-imposed lockdown take hold
driving the pair to nihilism and Madness
humankind reveals itself to be an
outmatched and overconfident species
misanthropic and enormous in its scale
phase 4 takes the Creature Feature
formula and endows it with a desperate
sense of fatalism
when a pair of employees at a medical
supply warehouse accidentally unleash a
deadly gas the malignant Vapors begin to
raise the dead what's more the warehouse
neighbors are a cemetery and a
crematorium in short this is a recipe
for disaster as the dead wrench
themselves back into the land of the
living they only have one thing on their
minds
one of the most confident directorial
debuts in Horror history The Return of
the Living Dead is a rare breed a horror
comedy that truly delivers on the horror
both in the gore department and in
confronting the existential probability
that mankind is going to Pratt fall into
its own destruction a seance unleashes a
horrifying glimpse of a long dead priest
and seemingly kills the woman who
experiences the vision while other
occult-leaning women attempt to warn the
powers that be of the bad vibes The Seer
herself who is very much alive is
rescued from her grave by a passing
journalist together the pair digs deeper
into the vision uncovering an imminent
prophecy of Undead Invasion arguably one
of the gnarliest offerings from Italian
goremaster Lucio fulchi city of the
Living Dead boasts unparalleled style
and a refusal to dial down any of its
apocalyptic spectacle the final product
is a miraculous and foreboding piece of
filmmaking
based on Michael crichton's 1969 novel
The Andromeda Strain begins with a
mysterious catastrophe the residents of
a rural New Mexico town all die after
the crash landing of a satellite the
only survivors are an alcoholic man and
a screaming infant suspecting the
satellite may have brought a vicious
alien organism into Earth's atmosphere a
group of scientists conduct an
investigation in a top secret lab armed
to self-destruct if any infectious agent
threatens to escape featuring science
fiction harder than a diamond with a
procedural bent that will satisfy those
with a love of 1970s conspiracy
Thrillers The Andromeda Strain is the
cruel Pinnacle of the killer virus
subgenre few end-of-day scenarios can
contend with the literally
earth-shattering catastrophe that befell
our planet roughly 66 million years ago
directed by Don Bluth the former Disney
artist who dominated children's feature
animation during the 1980s The Land
Before Time tells of a group of young
dinosaurs who are separated from their
families during unprecedented
environmental shifts as they Journey
Through the Wasteland the group is
hounded by predators and a planet Keen
to Snuff out their young lives as dire
ominous and distressing as any of the
adult films on this list The Land Before
Time is a masterful story of
perseverance Devastation and the
difficult necessity of accepting loss
even though it's supposed to be the
happiest day of her life Justine is
absolutely miserable throughout her
wedding she's doing her best but her
severe depression shows through the
cracks much to the embarrassment of her
controlling sister Claire meanwhile an
immense Blue Planet Melancholia is on a
collision course with Earth as the
gargantuan celestial object Bears down
on our planet Justine finds Elation and
peace in the promise of imminent
destruction Claire on the other hand
descends further and further into
anxiety and panic as her helplessness
gets the better of her weaponizing
cataclysmic destruction as a metaphor
for all-consuming depressive episodes
Melancholia is a masterful engulfing
necessarily draining watch
the year is 2027 and Humanity has become
sterile as Extinction looms the planet's
populace descends into martial law and
total Fury we follow Theo a former
activist who is recruited by his
anti-authority ex-wife to Shepard a very
special woman to Sanctuary no human baby
has been born in nearly 20 years and yet
somehow this woman is pregnant with a
startingly believable vision of dystopia
grounded in impeccably detailed
production design and Unforgettable
cinematography Children of Men isn't
just one of the best pieces of
apocalyptic fiction but one of the
greatest sci-fi films of the 21st
century aliens have invaded Earth and
not as Little Green Men but as
microscopic gelatinous spores capable of
imitating and assimilating into the
populace of prospective victims our hero
is Matthew bennel a lab scientist who
begins to grow wise to the
Extraterrestrial conspiracy as the signs
of subversive takeover peek through the
cracks the question is will he be able
to alert the powers that be before it's
too late who can he confide in when the
enemy looks like a carbon copy of the
people he trusts
for our money it's the fourth entry in
the Mad Max franchise that takes the
cake or more accurately the can of beans
or the barrel of gasoline in all honesty
there's probably no cake to be found in
this apocalypse but Mad Max Fury Road is
a cut above its predecessors a
feature-length car chase led by a
rebellious imperator attempting to
Shepherd a warlord's Brides to a safe
haven this film is a kinetic rock opera
of dust clouds skull embedded wheels and
dogged perseverance a modern classic
with a wasteland we are Keen to revisit
time and time again Mad Max Fury Road is
the shiny chromatic star of modern
apocalyptic Cinema they're coming to get
you Barbara for reasons are known though
radiation from a disintegrating space
probe may be to blame the dead arising
from their graves a group of survivors
fleeing the rotting hordes find
themselves Under One Roof where they're
forced to steady their fragile nerves
and work together to keep the flesh
hungry ghouls at Bay a groundbreaking
precedent setting contribution to the
apocalyptic genre Night of the Living
Dead set the stage for a Litany of
zombie films keenly interested in the
human response to the end of days even
more than 50 years passed its initial
release Night of the Living Dead refuses
to show its age
The Stir Crazy residence of an Antarctic
research station find themselves in a
lovecraftian nightmare when the dog they
rescued explodes into a fleshy mass of
spider legs and bull whip tentacles this
high-stakes murder mystery is less of a
whodunit than a who is it which unfolds
as the men are preyed upon by an
Intergalactic creature capable of
imitating organic life the gem in the
crown of John Carpenter's apocalypse
Trilogy which also contains the
exceptional Prince of Darkness and in
the mouth of Madness the thing is a
dread drenched Epic this is the way the
world ends not with a bank but with
miscommunication and politicians
fighting in the War Room however there
is also a bang for good measure
simultaneously one of the scariest and
funniest films ever made Stanley
Kubrick's satirical Masterpiece focuses
on a gaggle of politicians generals and
diplomats attempting to thwart an
unintended nuclear Holocaust instigated
by an American General maddened by
conspiracy theories horrifyingly
plausible and undeniably hilarious Dr
Strangelove is a classic for a reason a
guide known as a stalker in the film
Shepherd's two curious men through a
bizarre area known as The Zone
mysterious and forbidden the zone is a
physics-defying land at the epicenter of
an unspeakable extraterrestrial tragedy
in the core of the Zone lies their
destination the room a mystical space
that seems to Grant the deepest darkest
wishes of all who enter it directed by
the great Soviet filmmaker Andre
tarkovski stalker is an evasive yet
evocative take on science Fiction's
deepest questions
[Music]